growing up culture has a lot to do with
it and what you are expected to do is
sometimes driven by by what people think
you ought to be and so when I was
growing up in India you know you either
had to be a doctor an engineer so I said
okay fine I'll be an engineer and I
started there and and and that was good
I mean I enjoyed it never any good at it
I thought so I said well you know maybe
it'll be a good banker what do you know
but I I went from engineering and I went
into business school I had really
enjoyed that I really enjoyed economics
but and and you're right I mean I really
enjoy the subject of markets and how
decisions get made how it's real time
public policy economic policy these are
all exciting yet you know finding
exactly what to do with that you know
was not easy I you know started off
believing and thinking I would like
being in academics and researcher
teacher I do like that but I write I
like real world problems more and and
you know it all came together when when
when I wound up going to Morgan Stanley
Morgan Stanley back then was about 2500
people and it was it was the size of
some of the smaller private equity funds
today in some ways it was a different
era it's almost 30 years ago and that
was really enjoyable because I had a lot
of ability to do things I wanted to do
and and and I grew up through that and
and I've never really talked back as to
how I got from here to here to here lots
of interesting incidents that happen
along the way that they guide you but I
do enjoy the topic and you got to do
that I mean if you're not passionate
about learning if you're not passionate
about what you're doing you don't like
the subject matter you know might as
well go do something else and that's
that's a critical aspect of what makes
one successful I really never tried to
manage my career I never thought about
the future and that way I mean if you if
you you you couldn't write a novel
collecting the connecting the dots of my
career and say you're something that
could have been planned ever so it never
happened that way to me the most
important thing I learned was from one
of my teachers one of our professors
said look there are very simple rules
just figure out what you're really
passionate about and follow that just do
that secondly you know if you happen to
be passionate about something that's a
growth industry that's great by the way
that's that's what you should really try
and see if you can get passionate about
that and and lastly you know if you are
gonna go out and do something make sure
you do it with a company or people that
have the right values and that you
really like working with it
the most important decision I had to
make in my career the most important
decision I had to make was to go from
and being an individual producer
somebody who was really good at
something and really enjoyed doing it to
somebody who decided that actually you
know what I could enjoy becoming a
manager it's very different to be good
at what you're doing it's completely
different thing to say now I'm gonna get
my enjoyment by watching others succeed
that transition is a very very difficult
transition to make and and you know it's
one of those things where you have to
teach yourself that you go from being
the valedictorian to somebody who
manages valedictorians and there are
plenty of them here I know and how you
manage that talent how you nurture the
talent how you draw it was a very big
shift and that's probably the single
biggest shift that got me from what I
was a financial professional or somebody
who really enjoyed that to where I am
today
you